when did twilio start and then when did
you cross the one million mark in yearly
revenue
just different benchmarks so we started
the company very beginning of 2008 so
2008
myself john evan all three of us
developers and we had this idea we said
you know from my experience and all the
companies that i had started prior so i
had
started my first company when i was
still in college then i was the first
cto of stubhub
then i was one of the um or started a
bricks and mortar retailer actually
doing extreme sporting goods of all
things then i was one of the first
product managers at amazon web services
and when i left amazon was thinking
about what i wanted to start next
because i knew i wanted to start my next
thing
and i realized that every single one of
those companies
they're really two things in common
right first was the fact that we were
using the power of software
to build a better product and a better
customer experience than anything that
existed
uh to date in those industries and even
though like my startups that i had done
before were very different from each
other my first company was an
academic content company for college
students my second company
was you know live event tickets concerts
sporting events and stubhub
and then my third company was bricks and
mortar for skateboarding and
snowboarding and surfing like these
businesses could not have been more
different from each other yet
and every single one of them we were
using the power of software to build a
better company and a better customer
experience and to me that always meant
well you listen to customers you go out
and build something you put out there in
front of the customers you get feedback
and then you keep iterating your way
towards a better and better and better
product and a better customer experience
and the job of a software developer and
a software-minded company is never done
you're always listening to customers and
hearing how you can create a better
product and so that iterative spirit
of software was key to every company
that i had started prior so take stubhub
for example
we went from the first line of code
written to launch in six weeks
wow right that's like agile like that to
me is like this is what it's all about
uh but then the other common thread
among all those companies was that
you needed communications in order to
build a great relationship with your
customer
right and every time we ran into these
ideas we say oh well yeah if a customer
calls us let's
like we can give them this information
or oh let's reach out to customers when
this happens when their package ships
when their car is right whatever it is
and every time we said oh yeah that's an
amazing idea
but i'm a software developer like making
a phone ring like having some voltage
appear in a phone line somewhere in the
world like that's magic
yeah that works yeah and so we turned to
the companies that seemed like they
didn't know we turned to carriers or
like you know cisco and say how do we do
this
and every time it was the same answer
was like hey we can help you with that
you know first thing we're going to roll
out a bunch of copper wire
from a carrier to your data center then
we're going to rack up a bunch of like
telco
hardware then you're gonna buy a whole
software stack that's on top of it
and then we need to integrate it all and
then we need to integrate it with your
systems and build the thing you have and
so we're gonna bring in this army of
professional services
and that'll take two years and take
three three million dollars right sign
here we'll get started
and every time i was like wait a minute
hold on a second first of all millions
of dollars
to get started i'm like yeah it makes no
sense i don't have that budget but let's
say i did
you know what's more offensive than the
money was the time
yeah it's brutal this idea that like so
i have this idea and i will have to wait
two three years
before customers are ever able to tell
me if we're on the right track
if this experience is any good oh and
then they're gonna tell us a bunch of
feedback and tell us what we really
should have built
yeah it'll be another two years and two
million dollars before we
get that built i'm like this is the
opposite of software right and so we
started twilio beginning of 2008 with
this idea of saying how can we bring
software
or how can we bring communications into
the era of software
under the belief that the future of
communications was not going to be about
all those physical
wires and and servers and windowless
buildings but rather the future of how
we as human beings actually make use of
this technology
it's going to be about the software yeah
who's going to build that the software
developers of the world people like me
who in their company saw ways to
communicate with customers that would be
better
and just needed this in our tool kit and
so that's where we started